ça ils aiment bien ça y est alors
michael tu connais les quatre tirs ne
jamais mais je vais je vais découvrir tu
vois quelqu'un sait quelque chose et je
voulais revenir deux ans sur les quais
c'est vraiment un truc phénoménal avoir
cet été je les ai vus dans le gala de
eric antoine c'était hallucinant c'est à
dire que les québécois ne connaissent
pas montréal les a tous retournés en
deux minutes c'était phénoménal avec
sean au milieu attaque mais les fans de
toi mais quelle adresse votre acheteur
non mais vraiment je te dis on est fan
de toi continue parce que tu es vraiment
cessé c'est fou ce que tu fais moi mon
nez on n'est pas d'aller voir le
spectacle d'éric vraiment exceptionnel
une question bien sûr on y va aller
bonjour je m'appelle françoise c'est
bientôt noël
je prépare ma crèche dont je voulais
savoir est-ce que vous avez des
chroniqueurs en trop parce qu'il me
manque un boeuf et un âne je comprends
votre question chère française mais non
désolé c'est siri ne prête pas ses
chroniqueurs pour des prestations
privées car celui-là a besoin de tout le
monde à chaque intervenant a une
fonction bien précise en cette mécanique
de précision qui était pmtc qu'au regard
des missions comme ça c'est pas évident
vous est ce que c'est vrai le mieux
c'est benjamin vous explique le rôle de
chacun dans l'émission comme il l'avait
fait pour michel leeb le jour de sa
venue
lefebvre jeu
le jeu
m
je crois
je joue un peu
ça fait plaisir
l'iphone a requis sans rien nous à la
déconne il ay est un qui bafouille bon
résumé mais qu'il fasse attention
belgique parce que le connard et la
potiche là il voyait bien que les
regarder bizarrement non
il
ça va
jean soit au centre et c'est ça qui est
rassurant cette émission en fait
personne ne dit du bien de personnes
il ya un bel équilibre après je convie
tout le monde s'aime c'est ça qui allait
mais de loin a lens on sait qu'ils sont
toutes ensemble il faut que vous il faut
que vous lâchiez peut-être un peu mais
c'est à dire sur jean-luc un jour tu
viens pour [ __ ] la merde donner la
réponse les quatre tiers sur jean luc
fauré tournaire qui bossent ces jeunes u
boat a sorti tous les deux et les deux
vous partez en aquarium après
dans un va très bien elle est de la
layette se contente elle sa cote est
longue autant gens très contente sur le
magnifique on dirait muriel hermine
tiens un truc de natation synchronisée
merci voilà on leur a dit natation
synchronisée côte à l'est alors sais pas
si c'est simple pour vous de rentrée
dans l'émission mais souvent pour les
invités c'est un peu compliqué quand ils
débarquent ils viennent pour faire leur
promo ils voient des semis a connu
parler sérieusement médias et d'un seul
coup c'est même semi inconnu se met à
insulter les leila fois transition alors
c'est ce qui est arrivé à françois
berléand ah oui regardez bien choisi un
petit flottement quand même on va jouer
tout de suite avec artus avec nawel
répond soit à déchiffrer des
mais
je voudrais
m
là là françois était un peu perdu mais
il a quand même passé un très bon moment
notamment grâce à maxime gainey a qu'il
a découvert ce soir là ils le
connaissaient pas maxime devrait pas
donner de faux espoirs
mais je crois qu'il a beaucoup
impressionné par la qualité des
interventions
oui et notre miss france a été éliminé
d'emblée elle était même pas rentrer
dans le top 16
donc dans l'âge pour elle
poule à tel-aviv il ya un petit joueur
qui vous attend de se confronter à vous
ouais le joueur de tunis
et en plus on n'est pas assez bon alors
là non mais sur la tête de ma mère on
dirait que mais quand régis il a un
casque en fait j'écoute vase igloo suis
mort il faut que t'arrêtes pas tant
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible ça
dégouline mais revault une fois qu'on
pour m alors on va leur faire un nom ah
ben si je rappelle on est la seule
émission qui n'est pas en direct
exceptionnellement et qui se passe comme
si elle était en direct
force10 beijing
donc je crois maxime que françois été
très impressionné par la qualité de tes
interventions où tu as déjà entendu ça
et notre miss france a été éliminé
d'emblée elle était même pas rentrer
dans le top 16
donc dommage pour elle
poule à tel-aviv il ya un petit joueur
qui vous attend confronté à vous ouais
le joueur de tennis
à la décharge de maxime il faut que je
vous révèle un secret tous les
chroniqueurs ont perdu beaucoup de
diction de personnes hantées pmp c'est
incroyable et ça à cause de la pression
maxime par exemple quand il prend la
parole il sait qu'à neuf chances sur dix
pour que siri d'envoi au bout de trois
secondes en vigueur on s'emballe est qu
un nom donc pour éviter la sanction
voilà exactement donc pour éviter la
sanction il parle de plus en plus vite
et de plus en plus mal comme nous tous
jean-michel il ya sept ans sur france 4
c'était francis huster est en théorie
sauf que maxime est une particularité
quand il accélère il invente des mots
qui n'existent que dans sa tête
donc vous pour que vous compreniez bien
le comique préférée de françois berléand
je vous ai fait une petite compile les
nouveaux mots de maxime guesnier
le prochain rendez vous la prochaine
boîte de nuit à la boîte de nuit là
discret une belle discothèque
discothèque à la base elle était venue
pour un rôle de politique une politique
veut se confronter à vous ouais
le joueur de tennis à un joueur de tunis
à l'hebdo c'est avant tout un journal
cette idée qu à un journal satirique
bonsoir le champion du monde steijns a
indiqué les briscards qui n'équilibre
isc équilibriste qui a le goût du risque
mieux vaut avoir un profil de second
couteau pendant trois ans tout en disant
que profil de stars pendant trois prime
dès ce prime émission de ce première
partie de soirée
j'ai beau cadeau un cadeau virtuel c'est
vous dire offre si je vous dis bobards
obama peur de bologne by encore que tu
arrêtes tes flatulences intempestives là
parce que la barre à la castastrophe une
castastrophe flatulences de benjamin
castaldi
c'est pas parce que tu mets une période
pendant trois minutes dans une séquence
dédiée que ça va te décribiliser dans
nos contrées crédibiliser décribiliser
décribiliser actions de rendre quelqu'un
ou un cri bill
j'essaie de m'améliorer tous les jours
mais maintenant je prends le temps
d'appuyer tous mes mots bien appuyés
bien d'ailleurs sonné le temps la
semaine dernière vous receviez big flo
et oli qui vous ont fait un magnifique
cadeau cyril rice est vraiment puisque
ils vous ont offert une reproduction
dédicacé de leur disque de platine
c'est un grand moment magnifique
voilà ouais bon allez pas de l'annoncé
juste un grand moment carrière passée
voilà et je tenais à le montrer pour que
tout le monde en profite
parce qu'à l'antenne ce qui a été
diffusé c'est ça
c'était touche pas à mon poste technique
s'appelle anna gunn ça peut arriver sur
ce 8ème coupe le sifflet comme honda
c'est ça d'ailleurs avant d'aller plus
loin dans les cas tiers si vous le
permettez je préfère un peu d'auto promo
pour la chaîne amc nouveau que je sais
pas si vous avez vu comment ça se passe
d'habitude l'autopromo non le principe
est simple tu fais ta rubrique
tranquille et d'un seul coup tu te
prends une bande-annonce dans la tronche
mais c'est vrai mais vraiment assez
énorme ils mettent des trucs mais si j
avais vu ça les mêmes si tu parlais que
tu essaies devant d'une vanne et ils en
ont rien à péter away pour vous donner
une idée ça donnait ça ya quelques
semaines j'adore vous avez reçu beaucoup
d'appels ce soir là et notamment de
votre grand ami patrick sébastien ne
sais pas si vous souvenez n'était pas
seul il a voulu vous passer quelqu'un
c'était sympa mais chez les chroniqueurs
j'ai eu un gros malaise à cause d'une
mauvaise vanne arrêter ça voilà on vous
le demande comme un service arrêté mais
surtout les programmes sa chaîne tout le
monde non mais franchement des fois que
sur barbie si tu vois la gueule arriver
moi je suis persuadé que je joue là
parmi tous les jours que tu sais comment
c'est l'assassin et hop il ya un an on
va tenir ses plus beaux jours de ma vie
donc pour éviter ce genre de problème
j'ai accepté d'intégrer directement dans
la rubrique des séquences de promotion
pour d'autres émissions de la chaîne
voilà là c'est pour williams à midi bon
je préviens c'est pas moi qui écrit les
textes
c'est mathieu qui a conçu la bande
annonce
tu as mon coeur
c'était ma passion et rigueur
à midi
désormais votre nouveau rendez-vous
sevillana midi deschamps ça mon corps un
record d'audience hier williams amy tu
vivras gueule tu l'as pris celle pas
apprise dans les jeunes müller
évidemment c'est n'importe quoi il ya
plein de gens qui regardent l'émission
du diable que vient de lui dit il a
frustré moqueur ce mathieu mais il un
gros ego à rigaud le problème c'est que
cette année il a trouvé un sérieux
concurrent avec maxime gainey ah oui qui
derrière ses airs un peu propres et se
verrait bien la tête de touche pas mon
guide en six mois alors les deux côte à
côte
tu as un beau petit beau combat de coqs
un pur régal j'ai essayé de les
départager en toute objectivité
un peu comme si l époque monter la
demande à m
une ambulance
ce soit le tiens de ma carrière dans tpm
pétanque
mais là je n'ai pas donné mon coeur
possible a dépêché mais maxime un
avantage sur mathieu un atout imparable
pour continuer à faire le kéké
contrairement aux vieux jeunes il a
gagné un prime maxime c'est vrai et cela
ait lieu il l'a toujours pas digéré donc
la finale de ce combat va se jouer là
dessus c'est la mort subite
julien est un chic hôtel de manhattan il
m'a dit qu'il vend tellement ils peuvent
être payées cash et dégustent faire
démarrer sa cape
l'insolent des débutants comme ces
quatre mois selon à aider les cantons
prime j'ai pas entendu la date a dit
quoi nous laver ça va aller faire envier
le premier en 1 18 non non non vraiment
ça y est on a déterminé la thématique je
crois et c'est la thématique will son
départ sur la télévision forcément c'est
un spécialiste
on croyait allez passons maintenant au
top gène ans cette compilation des
petits moments qu'on peut être préféré
éviter dans tpm paix mais
malheureusement on n'a pas pu
c'est
les
nous repassons
mais
le magnanime touche ma chatte avoir sa
tête
mais en parlant de cigalon membres à
steven
ton qui monte sur la bâche
voilà la tête de choses c'était dans une
émission normale à la vanille au calme
ouais non c'était dans une émission
d'ora de laval mais je pense qu'elle
aurait fait la même s'il avait participé
à la spéciale johnny la semaine dernière
car vous savez en l'honneur de ce
monument la chanson nous avions
bouleverser nos programmes pour faire
une émission spéciale où chacun y avait
été de son hommage
alors certains ont parlé de deux
légendes du rock d'autres d'abord de la
scène d'autres encore dico des mortels
mais la phrase finale la plus émouvante
que c'est jean michel fut la sortie à
cet extrait c'est pas beaucoup fait rire
c'est juste comme un appel au secours
car j'ai regardé 52 quoi cette séquence
je n'ai toujours pas compris si c'est
quelqu'un peut m'aider j'ai remis ma
voix je fais toujours une 56 ans je sais
que je mourrais avant d'avoir vu
quelqu'un mouillé autant le maillot et
pernod ton dos sur un sol sur un concert
donc c'est de chez tesco merci
claude était au lot après midi mais qui
a compris cela
non mais franchement mais n'a rien
comment je l'a appelé pour lui demander
la mesure c'est vrai dimanche pas
compris ce que tu as dit même s'il ya
même lui merci merci merci merci
allez pour finir l'école ça fait
longtemps qu'on surveille mes camarades
ou boire un coup à la fois que c'est
possible au ralenti les images et comme
ça on a l'impression que tout le monde
est bourré ça s'appelle touche pas à mon
bistrot c'est parti
du smic elle fait plus rêver marines que
j'étais à evian un voyage éclair à lyon
quoi et surtout les la maison qu'on les
lui a franchement le mec qui s'y
connectent directement à fessenheim
il a une maison à l'est pas et les flics
et les nous on n'aurait pour rien
un copain qui était mineur
malheureusement copa et qu'ils aient
mineira et l'américano à mme lauzon à
celui
nesta sûr si tu mens grumes m'achetant
colline de baceux cristal autant j'aime
pas tous que nous ferons ce de
l'épidémie sont une chaîne services
publics autant dans ce milieu on n'est
pas atteint après ce show brévine l
endroit
en bref te plaît arrête à allouer les
hits et maman des deux marseillais
à miami les parents
ouais
messi